tourné vers la mecque est un film qui
vous propose une exploration intime de
l'islam aux antilles à travers les
regards et les témoignages d'anciens
chrétiens convertis à l'islam
ce film est totalement inattendu
verdoyant paisible loin des clichés
habituels et du spectaculaire qui fait
peur j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à
réaliser ce film parce que je suis allé
à la rencontre de l'autre
j'essaye de casser des préjugés et j'ai
trouvé la beauté dans l'autre et cela
lorsque mon métier de réalisatrice me
permets de le faire et bien si ce n'est
que du bonheur alors je vous invite à
venir avec moi et regarder tourner vers
la mecque
merci